Alright, now we're live.
Now we're live.
Okay, so...
Okay, first off, why am the fuck am I do- Why am I Doki E E Bird?
Alright.
So the game plan is to try- get evil harvesters?
What if evil harvesters were fun, right?
I think so.
Yeah.
I feel like they should, right?
They should land on one POI.
Just so- Well, actually no- Yeah.
So we just have to land right away.
Yeah.
Oh, cars are imp- Okay, that is so fucking stupid.
Temple- We need to get a car.
Cars are allowed, yeah.
Yeah.
We need to get a car.
Wait, you're all NRG.
Should I be NRG too?
Just to fit in?
Might as well.
Okay, wait, give me a second.
I'm gonna change my name real quick.
Watson.
Watson Octane Car.
Oh my god, no.
We have to get a car.
That's how I won the last- the very first Hide and Seek lobby.
We got a car and we just drove around.
Alright, let me- give me a sec.
Let me change- I'm- Just signed, by the way, guys.
I'm in NRG, guys.
I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- Okay, NRG.
NRG, Doki Bird.
Guys, I'm replacing their IGL.
They realized that a VTuber wishes better publicity.
Is it not a normal VTuber?
I mean, he's more like a poser.
He's a fucking poser.
That's real.
Remember when last time he actually used his fucking VTuber shit?
He's just a flush man now.
Yeah, he's a fucking fleshy.
He's a fucking meatbag.
Well, not even- everybody's not even in the fucking lobby yet.
Also, chat, for those who are like wondering who's who, the whale is Reptar for some reason.
And the cat is Fun.
And they're both used to be Rank 1 Pred.
So they're gonna carry me right now.
For charity.
This is Hide and Seek Tournament.
Yeah, in the Hide- In the Hide and- Yeah, yeah.
In the Hide and Seek Tournament.
They're gonna carry me in the Hide and Seek Tournament.
Thank fucking god I don't have to aim.
Anyway, I got signed to NRG, guys.
Real.
Post this article in Dexter right now.
Okay, does anyone- has anyone actually read the rules for this?
Like, like what's our first- is our first map World's Edge?
I know we play every map but Olympus.
Oh, we play every fucking map?
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, that's so fun.
What?
Okay, so what is the god spot on World's Edge, Fun?
Might as well just leak it now.
It depends on the- where the zone goes.
Where?
The icicles.
The icicles?
Okay, but if you know the spot, what if the other- what if the Seekers know the spot?
Well, there's a- isn't there- there's a zone.
Yeah, there is a zone.
It depends on where the zone goes.
Watch it go trials and it's gonna be 40- Dude.
Dude.
Stop.
If it goes trials, I'll be so sad.
Yeah.
We just bodyblocked the tower.
If it goes trials, Fun, I'm sitting inside of one of the trials- oh wait, we can't do the trials, never mind.
Wait, wait, Tempo's watching us.
Wait, Tempo!
Did you say icicles?
Guys, I think Tempo is sniping us.
He's gonna use me and make rules.
No, no, no.
Why is Tempo always watching us, Fun?
Why is this guy always watching?
Wait, why is he- why is he sniping us?
Why is he sniping us?
Why is this guy always watching us?
Alright, strats, I bet you the other pro players are just as scummy.
There's no way.
Yeah, don't talk to me like that.
I just got signed.
There you go.
Hey, at least, like, it's all for charity, guys.
Guys, it's all for charity.
We don't actually get paid.
We got free like Wi-Fi modems.
Are you guys using your Wi-Fi modem?
Are you guys using it?
Okay, I just wanted to be sure.
Yeah,
are you guys posers?
Are you guys using it?
Guys, we got sent like a care package.
That was like a... it's like a fucking Wi-Fi modem.
And it's just... it has an Apex Legends icon on it.
To like remind us that we're...
To remind us that it is a modem for Apex Legends.
And then... and then we got a shirt and a controller too.
Let's see.
Let me make sure all my settings and stuff are correct.
Alright.
Nice.
What the fuck is that?
I'm trash.
Oh, okay.
It's wake.
Never mind.
I don't know if I can get through this.
If you want, I can probably do it.
What is the controller gonna do?
Aim assist your hiding spot?
Controllers for driving.
Oh, true.
Get that roller out for the car.
Way fun.
I could sit in crypto and just give you full info.
Oh shit, you're right!
And I can get every single Evo.
Is that worth it?
Oh wait, yeah.
Yeah.
We should get...
Nah, we should run around.
Yeah, but the thing is, I'm not living longer than you.
Let's be honest.
That's true.
I might as well support you.
Yeah, yeah.
We're just pouring all our support onto fun.
We're just pouring our lives to blood to get fun Evo.
Yeah.
That's how I see it.
Wait, what should I play then?
What other character is good?
Oh, we should do like ring consoles and all that shit too.
Like, oh we should... yeah, yeah.
Play Vantage so you can hit bull.
Oh my god.
Wait, play Vantage so I can hit what?
You can hit both because of Vantage.
Oh yeah!
Okay, I'll do Vantage so I can hit the other shit.
And then like we just get... and so you know where the zone's ending, Fun.
You know where the zone's ending and where people are.
I gotta bring you guys both up on Discord.
Let's see.
Okay, Fun, you're already at 200% of the time.
Oh.
What the fuck is wrong with your mic, Fun?
I dropped my mix amp last night and I think it might have turned a bunch of stuff down.
Yeah.
You're literally at 200.
Wait, I have you at 200% too.
Hello?
Alright, Sound Guy, are they better now?
Well, I didn't really turn Fun up.
I just hope he did himself.
What are we waiting for?
We're waiting for... okay.
I'm scared I'm gonna be really loud.
Start without them.
Okay, no, that's toxic.
Hahaha.
It is, but we're also 8 minutes late.
Yeah, it's true.
Start without them.
I'll make up for their viewership.
When they heard that I got signed, they'll just be like, we gotta fucking go to her chat.
Yeah, you're still really low, Fun.
Raise yourself up.
Oh shit, they're gonna start without them.
Fuck yeah.
Just increase my gain.
Just all the way.
Yeah, just do it.
If Fun raises himself, I gotta set him down.
Just all the way up.
Yeah.
What are you scared of?
I'm scared of being a little bitch.
You're being loud.
That was like three years ago.
It still counts!
You're so loud now.
Hello?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
How did you get lower?
Like your voice is lower.
Oh, his voice.
I was like, you should go louder.
Like how did his voice get lower by more gain?
Oh my god, it got like so bassy.
Wait, Wig actually believed I got signed?
Wig, I did get signed.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna post my tweet in like ten minutes.
Alright.
Yay, we're starting.
Advantage, right?
This is like...
Yeah, you put advantage.
On King's Canyon, I think, I'm just gonna sit in the map room the entire game.
What if the fucking Seeker's got a map room?
I'm just gonna sit in the map room and I'm gonna spam the button until I get murdered.
I don't know that smile!
The sound it makes is so loud.
It'll get them all on one side of the map.
It's so loud.
I'm just gonna be on the other side.
Alright.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if their voices are better now.
Team 14's...
Who cares?
I'll be on team 14 if they're that desperate.
Then we'll be the team 14.
Don't do that.
It's okay.
Fun's gonna carry us.
No, Fun would just be carrying me then.
Why am I putting my sleeve on like I'm about to beam people?
I'm literally running.
You gotta climb.
You gotta put that sleeve on.
I'm literally running.
Yeah, just to...
I'm literally running for my life.
Just to like...
Get your running skills higher.
I don't fucking know.
APM that shit.
Put the sleeve on... put it on my keyboard arm.
Put the like...
Okay, I raised up... I raised up OBS.
Alright, let's go!
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Alright.
Vantage.
Where is vantage?
Guys, where's vantage?
Bottom left.
You got it.
Okay.
Nice.
Alone.
Wait, should I be like...
Oh, you're doing controller, right?
Your character can do both.
Oh, I can do both?
Yeah, once we have blue armor, you can do both with one of your perks.
Oh my god.
Okay, I didn't know that.
This is how little I played vantage.
Wait, Reptile, I thought you're fucking...
Oh, you're... Oh!
I can do...
Dude, should I...
Both.
Should I get...
You can't just keep healing and ring four?
Oh, wait.
I feel like you're gonna die before actually...
...setting that up.
Well, you have the five minute cooldown.
Let's go climb it.
We're going to climb it.
Okay.
There's going to be a lot of moving climate.
Yeah, yeah.
Just drop.
Who cares?
We got two counters.
All right.
Where even are the fucking...
So you can land on the beacon here.
Yeah, yeah.
On the height and hit it.
Let me just hit that real quick and find...
Where's the Evo?
...all the people that's just...
I don't know.
I'm like looking around for the Evo harvesters.
There's one in the open here and I don't see any of them.
Here you go.
Don't worry.
I'm getting us that 300 right off the bat.
Or 100, 200.
Just start blasting people with guns.
Yeah.
They won't know it's us.
When I started blasting...
How would they know?
I think I see it.
All right.
I need...
Guys, I need blue armor.
I can't fucking press that thing.
Okay.
We have enough time.
They're still in the ship.
Where's the Evo?
Spawn, damn it.
Spawn.
Where is it?
Come on.
We got to win this for charity.
That's what I'm saying.
All right.
We're going to get that.
Evo spawn in 20 seconds.
Come on.
Crafty bat.
I'm going to spread out.
I'm just going to go to Skyhook.
All right.
I'm waiting for this ring console.
I'm waiting for one of you guys.
Wait.
He already killed somebody.
Guys, he already killed someone.
That's fine.
They're in Mirage.
That's not my problem.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm just going to go to Mirage.
I'm alive.
So waiting on my ring console.
I'm going to grab the ments.
Friendly.
I'm going to...
I got you, Juicy.
Oh, it's over there.
I got one.
All right.
Wait.
Yeah.
Somebody get that one.
Or I'll get it actually.
No, no, no.
Stay on the beacon.
Okay.
I got it.
Yay.
Okay.
Ring console.
I got it.
Here you guys go.
I hope that fucking grappler isn't...
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
It's actually next to us.
Oh.
Yeah.
Is that a friendly or...
We'll go to Overload.
Friendly.
I'm so scared when I hear one-time footsteps.
I know, right?
I'm just like, am I about to fucking die?
Does anyone know what they're playing?
Guys.
I'm not going to like...
They might be Octane, to be honest.
I have no idea.
I know Timmy's on Pathfinder.
That's all I know.
All right.
So like, it's going to be...
Ghosting allowed.
Open the stream.
Open it up.
Yeah.
Talk to me in your chat.
You can tell you.
All I'm saying is that I somehow figured it out, but I just look at, you know, just look at my chat for like one second.
There's no rules against ghosting.
I would remember if there was.
All I'm saying, chat, is just tell me who they're playing.
Yeah.
We're getting metagamed.
What is this?
Wait.
Somebody figure out this Jason in the microphone.
I don't stand for this.
Someone go to Timmy's chat and tell him where Doki is.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait.
I was just joking, guys.
I was literally...
I was joking.
I wasn't.
What do you mean you weren't?
I'm literally your captain.
All right, guys.
I'm scanning.
It's a coup.
Okay.
We're going to go to the next one.
Who's that?
I don't know.
Wait.
The care pack.
The brick.
Oh.
That's big.
And steal the fucking Kraber.
Oh my God.
Look at everybody on our side.
If the Kraber spawns, we need to throw it off the map.
Okay, two of the shooter are the...
The Seekers are shooting right now, and I didn't hear anything, so they're nowhere near us.
Okay, okay.
That's good.
And the other ones are the People's.
Nothing to worry about.
All right.
They got me.
Steal the PK!
I will be sitting inside of the the underside of the tunnel.
Do you want to sit in the tunnel behind the fucking pills or some shit?
No, I'm sitting in the high spot.
No, you were on me.
There's no way they'll know I'm here, right?
No!
I fell down.
There's no way.
Oh wait, but here is this...
One ring to rule them all.
No, come on.
Is this like in bounds?
We're gonna find out.
Oh, it's not.
Guys, if I get shot, we'll know why.
That's a really obvious spot.
Yo, Rip, can you get on top of the balloon?
No.
Oh, what if they're... Oh, what if they're...
Oh my gosh, nobody will know I'm at the dildo.
Wait guys, I think I'm dead.
Wait, what?
Are you dead?
Are they there?
There's an octane right here, stimming.
I don't know if that's a person or not.
No, it's a friendly.
It's a friendly.
We're good.
Okay, alright, nice.
Cool.
See, nothing to worry about.
I just heard an octane stimming down my hallway and I got fucking scared.
Wait, can I do like more than one ring, right?
Oh, I can.
I can do a climatizer ring again.
Alright, I'm gonna leave you guys.
I don't want to be near all of you guys.
You guys are gonna hit double too.
Yeah, but what if they're there?
What if they're a climatizer?
Yeah, there's no way.
There's no way.
They literally start off at the end of the circle.
Probability-wise, I would survive more over that side.
The probability.
Yeah.
I'm very bad at math, but probability-wise, I think I'd survive.
Also, we have purple.
I don't think we're getting red.
Might as well just chill.
Yeah, but we can get intel.
Friendly.
Do I have enough meds for this?
Yes, I do.
Okay, so we're on one.
Yeah, I have syringes.
Oh, it would be a smart idea to carry guns.
Just to be like, ehhh.
Just to have all the friends run away.
Just to scare people, bro.
No, no, no.
Just so they don't think it's you, you know?
There's a solo on a balloon.
Sound solo on a balloon.
But they're all on the same team.
What do you mean they don't think it's you?
Dude, they won't know.
They won't know, bro.
They'll just be like, you have a gun?
You must get it.
Oh, he's got a gun.
No, that's a friendly.
You see a gun in your back and they're gonna run away from you.
And then you're gonna lead them to the actual seekers.
There's no rules against it.
It just says we can't shoot.
Just says we can't shoot, guys.
It says we can't shoot people.
Yeah.
And also NPCs.
And PvE.
Yeah, we can't shoot the NPC.
Okay.
I'm scanning the ring for us.
Getting that intel.
It pulls away.
Oh, hey, you guys are in zone.
It's possibly the worst spot for hiding.
Hey, friendly.
There's a friendly near me, too.
This is the worst.
Oh my god.
You guys don't hear shots, right?
No.
Okay, so they're not near us.
Dude, there's people in my tunnel.
That's fucked up.
How do we leave?
Where do I hide?
This guy's gonna get me caught.
I'm not.
Hey.
Get out of here.
Show your gun.
Should I just walk up to him with a gun and just start shooting the scene?
I just got punched.
Wait, what?
They don't have the punch?
Report them right now.
I just got punched by an Octane.
They started shooting at me.
Dude, this guy is like in my spot, but worse.
Is that Luda?
Or is that actually like...
No, it's probably a real person.
Or is that a... Is that a hider?
Probably a hider.
Why is he shooting me?
Wait, shooting you?
As in like actually shooting you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was shooting me with a hemi.
Oh, he probably looted then.
Oh, okay.
I'm putting him on the zipline.
Luda and Octane.
He's right here.
Where is he?
Oh, he's close to you guys.
That's him.
That's definitely him.
I'm out.
You guys... You guys gotta run.
I'm not moving.
Hide and seek.
Wait, somebody made a zip here.
That's scary.
All right.
If I run straight on, I might be dead.
No, no, no.
You're vented.
You're fine.
Just remember your ability.
You want to have your bird in your pocket already and then you hold it down, okay?
Okay, okay.
You don't like to re-throw it out.
I have my...
I didn't realize the bird was already out.
We'll have to help the scout.
Yeah, you gotta have the bird in the pocket and then you gotta hold down the button.
That's the rule.
The bird was already out, guys.
The bird was already out.
We'll put it back in the pocket.
All right.
Oh, there's another guy here with me.
I can grief them.
Oh my god, there's several people here with me.
I can grief all of them.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, what?
That's okay.
It's okay.
Hide and seek.
Am I dead?
I know.
This Valk is body blocking me into the corner.
What?
This enemy Valk is body... like they're holding me in a corner.
I can't move.
I'm about to punch this bitch.
I don't even care.
Like she literally has me body blocked in the corner.
Okay, look, they punched you once so you have like one freebie.
They didn't punch me.
They punched Fudd.
I can't...
Yeah, one freebie.
Oh, I jumped.
I'm out.
Quick, this guy.
Is that a Kraber?
It's a fucking Devo.
There's no way.
Okay, I'd rather have it be a Devo than a Kraber.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wait, is there... can I be under there?
I got apple juice.
There's no way they'd see me over here.
Guys, I hear an Octane stimming.
No, you don't.
Okay, you're right.
I don't hear anything.
I'll turn my audio off.
No, you don't.
If I don't hear it, they don't hear like anything.
Exactly, exactly.
There's no way they'll know I'm here.
I have like the perfect hiding spot in the open.
Oh.
Guys, we have to change our skins after this game or Fudd does.
He's all colorful.
Oh yeah, that's true.
He ain't hiding.
Fudd, where's... don't you know about the skin meta?
No.
Bro, you're supposed to change it to something worse.
I'm white in the mountains.
No, I... well... whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I didn't know it was this side of the map, you know?
Because it was obvious.
Come on.
I could've been... I could've been lava-oriented, you know?
Ooh.
Well, I hope that was not any of those guys that scanned the beacon.
No, no, no.
They're not allowed.
Oh, they're not allowed?
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Yeah, they're not allowed to scan beacon.
Ludu is right above me.
I'm in tunnel.
Wait, how do you know?
Do you hear shots?
He just killed that grouch guy.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna run then.
I don't trust myself being here then.
No, no, I'm not near you.
You're fine.
Oh, hey.
There's like other people here with me too.
Fudd is near you, not me.
You're good.
I'm across the map.
I'm gonna go across the map.
Fuck this.
Hey, guys.
You're going into zone?
Yeah, I'm going into zone.
Fuck this.
Actually, no.
The zone hurts a little.
What's that?
Guys?
I'll see you on the other side.
You dead?
I'm gonna go on the other side.
I'm going to travel across the map.
I'm gonna travel across the map.
I don't wanna be on this side anymore.
This side's scary.
I ain't doing no traveling.
Oh, there's people over there.
There's people over there.
Never mind.
I'm gonna travel.
Just stop moving.
I can't.
I'm sweating.
Find a corner and sit in it.
There's a dude sitting in this corner.
He's playing in-game fun.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's with you, Fudd.
He's with you!
Oh, Mirage.
Mirage.
Oh, my God.
Wait, Mirage.
Oh, yeah.
There's...
There's double aim assist.
We're fine.
There's double aim assist and it's not like you can shoot back.
Like, you get away for two seconds and be like, alright, where's the phone?
Oh, my God.
We should have had the gun in our backs.
We should have...
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, my God.
There's eight guys.
Oh, guys, leave me!
Leave me!
Guys!
Okay, he's where I am.
He's where I am.
Run!
He's where I am!
Wait, I'm resible.
Guys!
No, no.
All I'm saying...
No, no, no.
That was the most crazy I'm resible call ever.
Res me.
Res me now.
I was like, no, I don't think so.
I'm in tunnel 103.
Dude, like 300 meters away sitting in a corner.
I'm resible.
No, I saw Fun.
Fun was close by.
I saw him close by.
That's fair.
Dude, get away from me.
You see these guys?
What is this gonna be?
It was 100% resible.
I can't believe you guys won't res your IGL.
He knifed Greek.
That's to me.
Oh, my God.
Bro, you're so fucking dead at the moment.
You hit the road date.
No, Fun's not.
Yeah, ref.
No, you are though.
You're fucking dead.
No, I'm not.
I'm still alive.
How are you gonna do this?
You wanna see?
Yeah, I'm watching.
I'm watching how you...
Yeah, make the loudest sound you can.
Oh.
Wait, he has a gun.
Reptile.
He has a gun, Reptile.
He didn't hear or see anything.
I saw nothing.
Holy shit.
He's shooting in front of you, Reptile.
That guy doesn't know about the spot apparently.
Is that Timmy?
Was that fucking...
No, no, no, no.
That was Luda.
That was Luda?
Yeah.
Let's see.
Okay, Fun's also equally fucked.
I see him fucking running in the open right now.
With his glowing heirloom.
Doc's dead.
Oh shit, we're better.
Fucking noob.
Yeah.
Can't believe it.
That's why he's getting kicked off NRG.
He's not even getting kicked off.
He's already kicked off.
Oh yeah, he's already... Sorry, they already announced it.
Yeah.
Right here live in this hide and seek tournament.
Is when you find out.
Okay, there's like gunshots like literally right next to you, Reptile.
I don't know about this.
Oh.
Whoa.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, don't worry.
Is it okay?
It's all gonna be okay, don't worry.
Yeah, I feel so safe.
Wait, wait.
If you can like get behind him.
I'm getting this guy killed.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not letting him move.
He's not allowed to move.
I have him trapped in the corner.
That's an enemy.
That's an enemy right there.
That's Luda right there!
I have them both trapped in the corner out of zine.
Oh my god.
Wait, you do?
No, I don't.
I don't.
I lied.
Why are you playing Duck Hunt right now?
Why did you do that?
Because I need to get away from those guys!
Bro, he's coming for you.
No, he's not.
Alright.
What do you mean why am I playing Duck Hunt?
I don't want to be next to them.
Yeah, but I thought you said you wanted to get them killed.
I tried!
What do you mean?
I literally tried trapping them in the corner, but I couldn't.
Guys, this is a rank one prank.
Guys...
Guys, this is a rank one...
Oh, he's coming!
He's coming!
Find people!
Find people, Riftar!
I'm getting away from fun.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gotta find people.
That's a good job.
Find people!
If you're gonna die, you gotta take people with you.
No, it's okay.
They can't.
Yeah?
I found one!
Oh, oh yes!
Dude, kill this guy!
Not me!
I found him!
Look, look, look!
He just all three feet away.
That guy didn't even get the... Like, he didn't even die for that!
He didn't even shoot him!
That's the worst part!
Fun, please.
You're our only hope.
You are our strength.
Remember, we put all our resources into you.
Oh.
Wait, that's friendly.
No.
Those are both friendly.
Oh, that's not friendly!
That's not friendly fun!
Fun!
I think he's... Fun.
You're okay.
He's gonna get distracted.
He's gonna get distracted by that path.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see that.
Oh my god, what happened to the model?
The model fucking...
Go on, I'm Res-able.
I'm Res-able too.
Wait, we should play somebody to craft us.
Yeah, that would do a lot in this situation.
Yeah, not gonna lie, we could have got... We could have 100% been crafted.
Come on, you can get top 10.
I believe in you.
Wait, that guy is... He's playing Lifeline or Sophras.
I think.
Oh, maybe not.
Wait, that's so smart.
Wait, what the fu... Who's he?
Drop him out of zone phone.
That guy died right next to you.
He literally died right next to you.
Guys, top 10.
We're top 10!
It doesn't matter anyway, but we're still top 10.
No, no, no.
It does.
We need top 3.
What do we do when we're top 10?
We top 3.
Top 3 is the only placement that matters.
We're gonna charity even harder.
Okay, fun.
We saw that.
Dude, why did he come back?
I don't know.
That Pathfinder is evil.
It's okay.
We got top 10.
Why did he come back?
That Path... Dude, what...
What the fuck?
How did he not see this guy?
I should have gotten that Pathfinder killed.
I should have went for the Pathfinder.
Yeah, you should have.
What is... Oh no.
How is he just sitting there?
How did he just let him sit there?
How did Tempo live that long?
Was that Tempo and Path, bro?
What's that?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure the Path died.
Oh my god!
He did it!
That guy literally stood in between the rocks!
Yeah, he stood still for so long.
I can't believe it.
This is a scam.
I'm playing Ultir.
I got scammed.
We got scammed.
We got scammed for charity.
That dude sold my spot.
I shouldn't have moved if I didn't move.
True.
Yeah, he heard you.
He heard your fucking movement.
It's okay, guys.
We placed higher than Nocturnal's team.
Honestly, in life, that's all that matters.
Yeah, that's all that matters.
That's why I'm the better IGL.
Dude, they had 71 kills.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Holy moly.
Hey, we got top 10.
Let's fucking go.
Who was it?
Where's Dolphins team?
Oh, was he the guy that like, ratted you out?
It won't let me...
It won't let me... It won't let me view his skin.
Oh, is the lobby broken?
Wait, how is it broken?
The in progress...
He said, can hiders pick up ammo?
No.
Why are we...
Oh, yeah.
They're running out of ammo.
They're shooting us.
Yeah, fuck you guys.
You don't deserve ammo.
Zach Mazur, you're trying to kill my friends.
No, I won't help you.
Go craft your ammo.
Someone said I'm not a Fortnite Lava.
Yeah, if you run out of ammo, just fucking punch.
We will take the Kramer.
Wait, what map is next?
There's no?
One of them.
I don't know the order actually.
Tournament.
It is King's Canyon.
King's Canyon?
Oh, okay.
Same comp?
I'm playing Altair.
Oh, Altair.
Okay.
I'll be Vantage.
I'll scan everything.
Yay.
I bet you the people...
People who aren't there just haven't... didn't wake up in time.
True.
What if we just play Res Comp and they run out of ammo?
That's so true.
Okay, one of us...
If it was three strikes, I'd be down.
I'll do it.
That's why Newcastle, like, what's... like, they're gonna run out of bullets, right?
Yeah, but that means we gotta stick together.
Three people running in a pack is not hiding.
I mean, like, there's just one guy's chasing us.
We just keep losing.
Just keep dancing on the shield.
Wait, actually...
Just keep resisting.
Actually...
Okay, what happens in Final Zone, though?
What about Final Zone?
We're still alive.
We wall off ourselves.
We actually win the game.
We wall off Newcastle ourselves against a rock.
Oh, you're right.
We outnumber them by sheer willpower.
Alright, we'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
We'll see how this goes.
No, we should do it for one game at least.
We should do it when we get a car.
Oh my god, yes!
Storm point!
Newcastle!
Newcastle, Lifeline, and who's the third?
We just play Watson?
Just give us shield gen on the car?
Can we put a gen on the car?
Yeah!
Give us shield gen on the car.
Can we put two on the car?
No, I don't think so.
I think it only has the one spot on top.
Put it on the front and the...
Wait, can we not put it on the back?
I don't think so.
Wait, you're right.
You might be able to.
No!
Wait, we could try.
We might as well.
The armored car strat.
If we're gonna have a car, we have to play Lifeline though.
Wait, you might wanna...
Wait, I might wanna play Path for this map.
When King's Canyon?
Zip over.
I'm playing Altar.
Yeah, I'm playing Vantage.
Don't worry, we got this.
The heavy armored car strat.
The armored car strat.
Put Rampart walls on it.
We just play Gibby.
We just play Gibby car.
They can't kill us.
No, I'm not even kidding.
Wait, that's true.
Wait, what do we do?
Gibby, Newcastle, Lifeline.
I mean, I'm...
We'll hide in the open.
Yeah.
Hide in a car in the open.
They can't get us.
Or should we do like Gibby, Newcastle, Watson or Gibby, Newcastle, Lifeline?
Oh yeah, well, that's probably...
Maybe we skip Newcastle.
Maybe we just do Gibby, Lifeline, Watson.
Oh, Gibby, Lifeline.
That rest is gonna be very tricky.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's not for the rest.
It's for the car.
We just live in a car forever.
We just... the car is our rest.
Okay, Gibby, Lifeline, Watson.
Nice.
We got it, guys.
We perfected the strat.
Because the thing you have to think about, right?
The Seekers aren't working together.
And if we're in a car, how are they gonna kill us all out of a car?
Oh, that's true.
That is so fucking true.
I feel like we should get another car just to distract the other... the main car.
Yeah, but then we don't have Bubble on both cars.
Oh, shit.
Yes!
We're living because we have Bubble.
No, no, no, no.
The Lifeline.
The Lifeline gets... oh, wait.
But then what's the point of having a Lifeline?
We can't rest.
All I'm saying is that we could have one Proust.
I feel like we can, like... first, we start off with two cars.
And then use the other car to distract people.
And then after the zone starts getting smaller, we, like... we go... we merge our cars.
We scatter cars.
We have three cars.
There are no cars in KC?
I know we're planning.
Yeah, we're planning ahead.
We're planning for Dexmed.
Yeah, yeah.
We're 50 steps ahead of The Seekers.
This game, we're gonna be tree-gang.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're right!
You're right!
They're gonna be shitty at trees!
Wait, that means like every... all of them will think that we're in trees but I'll be like in the open cause they'll know I'm not expected.
They'll be too busy looking up.
They won't even look at the actual map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They won't expect looking up.
I wish there was pruning in this game.
I would just prune.
They would never see me.
We should land somewhere with holds.
Rue.
I thought you were going to be at Map Room.
What happened to the Map Room?
We can do the double hold.
Yeah, double Evo on the hold and then hit Map Room for Insta Blue.
Oh, true.
You don't even need to play Vantage.
You can play Movement.
No!
Because we can hit Map Room on this map.
It shows us the world.
I hope Map Room is not in zone.
So I'm useful.
So I'd be useful.
I hope Map Room was just out of zone.
You got to start pointing your ult at people.
At other hiders.
Oh!
Seeker.
You're right.
Oh, it's first!
Are we all just going to land on Map Room?
Yeah.
We just live there.
Should I just open the hold with ult here?
You can't anymore.
It's patched.
No, I'm pretty sure you can.
We all live here now.
I think it's patched.
I'm pretty sure they fixed the crash, but I think you can still go through with ult here.
Guys, I feel like if we all live in Map Room, I feel like all the Seekers are still there.
I feel like we're just going to run Mach 10 to the Map Room.
Have a look.
Yeah, but they'll see the Map Room scans.
Oh.
What is it?
Hit ours first.
Or am I just crazy?
Nice.
It's not a grenade fun.
Wait, does each scan give you armor?
No, not from this.
I don't think Map Room gives anything.
Just the first one.
Oh, okay.
So I'm just going to go do this then.
I think it does.
I have a grenade.
But actually, no.
I'm going to go do downslope.
All right, so Reptar is going to live in the Map Room because it's not in zone.
Hold on, wait, hold on, wait.
All right, go.
All right, I'm going to go to this other scan.
I think we get blue here.
Oh, we will as soon as the thing's popped.
Yay.
Oh, yeah, you can just go hit the beacon.
It'll be fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll get it in the beacon.
Dude, this Geo Kinto guy died fast.
I think he died first last game too.
I don't think that guy knows how to hide.
I think he just lands wherever the Seeker is.
He's just like, oh, there's nobody going over here.
Let me go over here.
Yeah.
All right, we'll know where the Seekers are from this.
Why is everybody in air base?
What the fuck?
What's wrong with them?
The game ends, I guess.
Oh, my God, an air base ending?
We need to go.
We need to go on the outside under the stairs.
Okay, don't worry, guys.
I've got the scan too.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
You want to go get the hold over here, Saf?
We got this.
All right, I'm going to head to Relic for more scans.
All right, if I die, don't come to Relic.
Good goms.
No, it's okay.
I think they're going to murder air base first.
Yeah, they have to.
Look, Zac's dead.
Bye, Zac.
I swear, I have like the worst fucking...
I don't know.
I don't know if here they're going to curse because that's a shooting...
What if like I shot somebody's foot, like, is that illegal?
It's not allowed.
Do you have a laser pointer?
I think I use it as a laser pointer.
I'm just pointing at other people.
Why?
I just start pointing at people.
They're going to be like, stop, dude.
Bro...
Okay.
If you want to live long enough, I can use that as a laser pointer.
And just point people out.
You have a grenade ripped?
Oh, I got one.
I'm grabbing...
I grabbed another one.
Alright guys, if I die in Relic, don't come there.
Alright, heading over.
These are all my scopes.
And barrels.
All these attachments are mine.
I just hope... I hope this...
Dr. Loyal?
Wait, we can put it somewhere.
I think you do.
Or do I take the minus 10 second cooldown for IQ?
I think the infinite one because it's so hard to see.
That's true.
Dude, we can go put it in endgame.
And run away.
In endgame and run away.
True.
Oh, like the deploy deploy?
I don't know what that guy is doing.
I'm scared.
No, no, no.
My ult... Have you played with Ulti?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He got the CP ult.
Alright.
I'm gonna go up on the...
Alright, I'm gonna go craft a...
Actually, I don't need... What am I crafting?
I mean...
I'm gonna go grab these scans.
I'm gonna go craft a bat.
Yeah, I'm gonna go craft a bat just in case.
Four cells.
Oh, they're scanning too.
Alright.
Leave.
Leave!
I wanna scan as well.
Alright, you'll see where people are here.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Those are... Those are hunters.
Containment hunters.
Oh!
No!
Relic hunter.
Oh my god!
I thought he was friendly!
You don't look friendly.
Guys, I'm so Rezable, guys.
Don't head to Relic, but like...
Yeah, I'll see you soon.
Timmy's there.
Guys, all I'm saying is that Timmy will leave.
I can do it.
I can get the banner, actually.
Wait, you get my banner and then you eat back home.
We'll see.
We'll see about that.
I swear, RuffTard.
That would be the smartest thing you've ever done in your life.
Wait, are you actually gonna do it?
You're fucking...
Not anymore, I'm not going to.
What do you mean?
I'm not gonna do it.
What the fuck was that?
No, it's not Timmy.
What do you mean by that's the smartest thing I've ever done in my life?
It's not Timmy!
I swear to god, it can't be him.
He has to have moved on.
He moved on!
Don't be a little bitch!
Why am I getting roasted by my dead teammate?
What is going on?
Because I'm your IGL.
I'm gonna plug you in and he's gonna kill you.
See, he's okay in the Rez me.
Okay, we're gonna do it.
We're so fucked.
Timmy's gonna run at us, bro.
I'll see you later.
Bro, Timmy's gonna run at us.
Oh, you plugged him?
You plugged him?
Yeah.
See you later.
Chuck bait.
Ooh-ha-ha.
Okay, this was a bad idea.
This was such a bad idea.
I don't know why you guys did this to me.
This has to be the worst idea we've ever came up.
No!
I got you!
Guys, leave this place!
Luna's right here!
Luna's...
Wait, no, it's we the people.
Riptar, I'm so reasonable.
I'm going for round two.
All I'm saying, Riptar, is that he'll leave.
Okay, okay, no, Riptar, don't go for round two.
We might need you.
Fun's gonna die.
You're our only hope for charity.
No, Fun's alive.
Fun's alive.
He's fine.
I don't know about that.
Sir!
Live is...
Wait, is that Timmy?
No, that's Luna, I think.
Timmy's on rev.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What... what...
Get the movement!
Oh my god, that's my number rank one friend!
Right there!
Bro, he's just chasing you.
Wait, are you actually getting me?
Wait, I think you... I think you can get fun after.
Fun's alive!
What do you mean?
I hit this man!
Oh.
I punched him on accident!
Dude, why are we playing rev and using Havoc?
They're on rev path because they're competing against each other.
Yeah, because they... they get to win more for charity.
Yeah, first place seeker wins ten grand.
Yeah, for charity, right?
Yeah.
I was gonna say, if they get ten grand alone, and like, none of us win any money, that'd be so fucked up.
How does this tournament even work?
So, like, the... the seeker that kills the most people, basically they get to choose, like, ten... pick a charity to donate ten grand to of their choice.
And the hiders team that wins the most points by hiding the most gets to pick the charity we want to donate to.
That's basically it.
Chat.
I'm sorry, bud.
I'm just getting Havoc'd.
I'm too far away from you to get your hand.
Rift, I don't know if this is a smart decision, so, like, let's hope that the seeker goes for me and not you.
I'm just gonna kill somebody.
I don't give a fuck.
For charity.
What are you gonna do, deduct your money from charity?
Yeah, right?
That's a mirage.
You know a seeker would never play mirage.
They can't take money away from charity.
It's fun.
No, but tempo can punish me, so...
Yeah, guys, by the way, guys, have you heard about Nokia Apex?
The Nokia Wi-Fi modem where you can play tournaments like this over Wi-Fi?
Wowee.
We're so fucked.
I love Wi-Fi.
I love Wi-Fi too, guys.
We're all on Wi-Fi here.
All... every single one of us...
is on Wi-Fi.
You think I can do a ring scan?
Ooh, I don't like the sound of that.
That was me.
Oh, that was you?
Okay.
I'm just letting you know we're over here.
Wait, what?
I definitely don't like the sound of that.
I fucked up my echo, but that's okay.
Wait, I think I might die to zone, so that's not okay.
Oh, no, you're fine.
It's only zone 2.
You'll be good.
I'm just letting you know we're over here.
Oh, oh, oh.
You're okay.
It's fine.
Um.
What?
You can't just say, um.
What is it?
Is a seeker dead?
Wait, what?
Why?
Chat said Luda died.
How did he die?
How did he fucking die?
I was all tapped, but apparently he's in the kill feed.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
He got shot.
Did you shoot somebody?
Yeah, I killed him with my PK that I dropped.
I punched Timmy.
Wait, he fell.
Oh, my God.
He fucking fell.
He fell.
How do you fall?
There's, like, no way to fall.
Oh, there's definitely ways to fall off the map.
What?
But, like, in one...
It's probably an air base.
Just fall off the map or some shit.
Oh, that's pretty fucking stupid.
Well, it's just Timmy versus people, then.
What happens if all the seekers fall?
Oh, that would be great.
What if I just carry this gun around?
Then everyone wins.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, yeah.
No, nobody's getting grenade off my body.
Yeah, do it.
Yeah, I don't think I can.
It does.
That's why you had to...
Alright, I'm heading over.
What if I do a scan?
Should I do a scan?
Alright, they're gonna know I'm here, guys.
They're gonna know I'm here.
Here you go.
Alright, look.
These are all the people.
Wait, did you... Wait, it doesn't show for me.
Oh, it doesn't show?
Oh, wait.
Okay, now you know.
It's because I'm dead.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Okay, so...
Luda got alter-kidnapped.
He got alter-kidnapped?!
Off the map, bro?
That is...
That is actually too funny.
Okay, that's actually great.
Wait, that's actually fucking hilarious.
Anybody got a clip?
Timmy's right beside me.
Dude, I ran into NoName and Timmy's just standing in the middle of the fucking road like it's a goddamn wild west.
Why is the Nexus so far, Raptor?
Yarrr!
Well I placed the Nexus and then I opened a pill on it and it broke it.
Nooo!
Oh this is a fuck zone.
That would have been my fucking lifeline right there.
Okay I have Nexus at 18% again.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Rep, you know the pipe on the second...
Outside?
Yeah, outside the window.
You can go up above the window.
That guy has an Energize dip.
I don't like that.
That's not...
Wait, Energize is good.
Energize is good.
I'm pretty sure the path is dead.
Timmy's on Rev.
Timmy's on me!
Don't come here!
But you know this spot I'm talking about?
Like right here.
Like right here right?
Yeah.
And then you can go up and down freely.
But there's also the other one.
As well.
As like the alcove.
Man if only I had that fucking beacon there.
It wasn't close enough to you.
If only I had that beacon.
Go to the other one.
The other one's better I think.
Cause it has a ledge.
Oh.
That's a friendly person.
No it's not!
That's gunfire.
That's a friendly person.
That is so friendly.
That's not friendly people.
Bro that was obviously what the fuck.
Uh.
I thought it was a friendly person.
Wait peeps dead!
Finish her!
Wait how did he die?
Peeps died to zone.
Wait.
Oh I could've lived.
I'm sad now.
How did he die?
He died to zone.
Cause he's a noob.
And he stimmed himself to death.
Wait really?
You could've won that!
Oh wait.
Wait I think Timmy could die then.
He doesn't have enough ammo for this.
Boom.
Boom Razzle punched him too.
Hahaha.
Maybe he's just getting bullied.
Well Timmy could literally just win the charity tournament right now by farming all these people.
I'm gonna be honest.
I think he's already won.
Yeah.
100%.
After this one yeah!
Oh bro.
We should be seekers.
Honestly if you die to zone you should rotate.
You should get rotated out.
If you die to zone.
Okay guys.
We have to We have to like... if we... we have to like kidnap one of them off-zone then.
Like how the fuck is Timmy gonna have enough ammo for this?
Bro, he baited... he got baited into an altar ult off the map.
Wait, do you have the clip?
Yeah, I got a clip.
Wait, wait, wait, DM DM, I wanna see, I wanna see.
It's so good, it's so good.
DM DM DM, share it.
He's actually staying away.
Here you go guys, we're watching it live, I'm watching it live with you guys.
Let's see, what is this?
Wait...
Wait a minute, what?
Oh my god!
That is actually amazing.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, that's actually crazy!
Bro...
All I'm saying is, if you get... if you get fucking baited off the map, you should get rotated out.
If you die to zone, you lose seeker privileges.
Yeah, you lose seeker privileges.
Bro, all the hiders should just gang up on him.
And just punch him out.
One... one seeker left.
Yeah!
When he gets to ring six, the hiders can fight back.
The hiders should all just punch him into the zone.
They should just like all surround him.
No, because there's gonna be...
He's just waiting, he's just waiting.
There's gonna be more hiders, so he should like... the seeker... the hiders should just like... bodyblock him out of zone.
Just put four of them...
Bro, this is Malcolm just living right next to him, bro.
What am I watching?
Kim is looking like me, what the fuck?
That was Kim?
That was Kim.
There's another rez?
He literally was just like holding his head.
Like, yo, what the fuck?
Yo, what's up, guy?
He's like, what the fuck do I do?
Wait, did he run out of ammo already?
I think he's just waiting.
He's con... concerned.
He's like, Loba.
Put your ult down now.
Loba, put your ult down or I won't shoot.
Bro, I don't even think an ult's gonna help them.
Wait, that guy's just rez-ing right next to him?
I don't think he has bullets.
He's trying so hard to find ammo.
The seeker's hiders should...
A thermite!
Oh my god, E-Rob.
They're meleeing people.
Oh, an R9?
Bro, that's a waste of ammo, Timmy!
You shouldn't be wasting ammo like this!
Might as well do finishers!
You're losing ammo!
He's losing time right now.
There's still 16 squads and 20 hundred rez beacons.
There's still 32 people alive.
You think I was really...
I mean, I could've lived in this fuck.
Who the fuck had a gun on them?
I'm stuck on now.
He's trying to grapple again!
Wait, that was a crazy jump.
He said, hello!
Hello!
Poor Timmy.
He was like, maybe he has ammo.
What are the odds?
Bro, he's over-sensitive right now.
He's overwhelmed.
There's too many people going around.
You gotta finish the job, Timmy!
Where the fuck is he?
Dude!
Wait, are you good?
Oh, that was a good shot.
That was Mandy.
Oh my god, you're right!
There's so many!
I died three times, which meant like...
I made him waste his ammo three times on my body.
Yeah, true.
He should just give up at this point.
He's not killing anybody else.
Someone please don't make a loud noise, bro.
He's like, thank you.
No, but why?
Tim, take it down.
Holy shit, bro.
Holy shit!
G-Dolphin is a G, bro.
Bro, that was G-Dolphin!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, it's personal.
That was amazing.
The grenade!
They're fucking pushing him out of zone!
Oh my god, they're all dead!
There's so many!
Holy shit!
No way!
Wait, Timmy's gonna die early.
Timmy's dead!
What is this?
Look at that, those bodies.
Okay, that was crazy.
It was fucking crazy.
Dude, you just whip out the Watts at all.
Did I play Caustic?
I didn't play Caustic, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Played Caustic and killed nobody.
You're not allowed to do damage abilities.
No, no, as a Seeker, you just don't even seek.
Yeah, you just wait until end zone.
That only works because two people died to zone.
If you get there and fall off the map.
Holy shit, I can't believe that happened for the Seeker team.
Glad we aren't doing Olympus.
At Seekers.
Rotate Seekers.
Embarrassing.
Bad macro.
Timmy's like looking for two.
I volunteer.
As the newly assigned NRG member.
I'd never die to zone.
I can't believe, who did that?
Who baited Luda?
Who even baited?
Does anyone know who baited Luda?
Did anyone bait Luda there?
For that to happen?
Is that whoever that guy is?
He's a fucking king.
Apparently it was Linkser.
Linkser did it.
It was Link.
Yeah, apparently it was Linkser.
Linkser.
You baited Luda.
DQ game for the kill server.
Wait, DOW's got a kill?
Oh, probably just from...
I don't even know how you'd get a kill on accident.
How did Peep...
How did Peep die?
Peep died to zone.
He literally...
He stemmed himself down to one and died to zone.
Yeah.
I feel like that's like...
Dolphin Adelieke troubling them.
I feel like that's almost as embarrassing as getting...
No, that's worse because he did it to himself.
He knew he had one HP.
Now we're on storm point.
Karstrat, Karstrat.
Who's playing what?
Because we're doing...
Did you just play the movement comp on the car?
Are we doing like...
Aren't we armoring Karstrat?
Should I just play Gibby?
Maybe we don't need everything.
Maybe we just need Gibby.
Gibby, Lifeline, Watson.
No, we need Doki Gibby.
Wait, why me Gibby?
That's a lot of responsibility on the bubble.
Yeah, that's a lot of responsibility.
I don't even know how to put the bubble correctly.
No!
No cars!
No cars, PBE?
No cars?
No cars, I'm mad.
We're just playing movement comp.
So what's that?
Path, Rev, Loba.
Path, Rev, Octane.
Or Octane.
I'll do... wait, what are you guys going to do?
I don't want to give them ammo but also Ulti-Cells.
Ulti-Cells?
Yeah, picking up Ultis...
I mean...
You play Loba.
I'll play Path.
And then...
Then we have the Revtar.
Okay, I'll be Loba then.
And we're just grabbing Ulti-Cells.
Yeah.
Ulti-Cells and bats.
Hopefully.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
We had the Armored Car strat!
It was going to be the strat!
Yeah, Tempo's just...
He's kind of an asshole.
Yeah, he knew.
He fucking knew.
He heard we were about to have fun and he was like Yeah, let's shut this down real quick.
Run bang, let's hotbox the end zone.
Ooh.
Nice.
The only reason there was actually an end zone in that game was because there was only one hider.
She tried to outplay the...
Outplay the Seekers.
Oh, true, true.
Put a loot stick in front of a door so they can't leave.
They can just kick the door down.
Jam the door.
There's just a bunch of Rampar walls on it.
Wait, that's so smart.
We bait one of them into a room and then put like 200 Rampar into a room.
So he can't get out.
Wait, what map are we playing after this?
Broken Moon?
I guess so.
Oh god.
I can hide everywhere on that map.
I don't think anyone's gonna be dead.
Alright, here it is.
This is it.
Yay.
Guys, it's okay guys.
No matter what placement we get, in the end it's all for charity.
True.
For charity!
For charity and Wi-Fi.
Yeah, for charity and Wi-Fi.
Hey guys.
What's the website again?
The Apex Wi-Fi?
Apex over Wi-Fi.
Guys, Apex over Wi-Fi.
Okay, I don't have the command because I'm on YouTube.
But if you go to Reptars and Fluff Fun Stream, which I assume they have the command, right?
I do, I do.
The exclamation point, Apex over Wi-Fi.
You can join a giveaway!
For free stuff!
Hashtag ad.
But we're not getting paid.
So it's not a hashtag ad.
We're just saying it.
We're just really passionate about Wi-Fi.
In fact, NRG is gonna play their World Cup with Wi-Fi.
Yeah.
As the IGL.
Fluff Fun is like, I hope not.
You changed the router.
As the IGL for NRG.
I will make sure that they will play on Wi-Fi.
Don't worry guys.
I'm here for you, Nokia.
Sponsor me.
For real.
No cars slash PVE for hiders.
He said it four times and then somebody said, can we use cars?
No PVE?
But why would we use cars?
Because cars win.
He's collecting the cars.
Down to sacrifice our points just to have a car.
Honestly, same.
DQ to get first.
Wait, it might need to play Octane.
Wait, but that means like...
Wait, they said that high...
Seekers can use cars, right?
Yeah, but they can't shoot while they're driving.
We need to set up road traps where they just get hit by Octane pads on their car.
I'm just thinking like...
What if we just take the car and then scare the other hiders?
Just be the roadblock of the journey.
Just make it more fun, but get DQ'd.
He's not gonna actually...
I mean, we just scare one guy.
My middle name is Zone Damage.
Who will die to spiders?
Oh, that's true.
Because there's no PVE.
They can hit us, but we can't hit them.
We can't hide in prowler areas.
You just run.
No, you can.
Because the prowlers will stop spawning.
Oh yeah, if there's more than one team, yeah.
Here we go.
I believe.
I believe in us.
Seekers got...
Seekers and Tens this...
Oh yeah!
That's actually fucking crazy.
Camp the cannons and when they try to push you, just take it.
If they take it, take it back.
We need to collect a million bats so we can just bat every time we take a cannon.
That's true.
Or we put an altar portal down and teleport out of the cannon.
Oh my god, that's so smart!
We wait at the cannon.
How do we kill them?
Well, we can...
Teleport them off a cliff.
Make a rave portal at the cannon and the portal ends at the edge of the cliff.
No, make a portal and then the portal ends at an altar or an altar queue or something.
And then it's just like a little road map to the end of the cliff.
It's just a domino effect.
Yeah, it's just a domino effect.
It's just a portal, portal, portal, portal, death.
Wraith, altar, ash.
Three portals.
That has to be like at least 100 meters.
Maybe 150.
Maybe more.
Yeah, we can get 150 meters off of that.
Wraith, altar, ash.
Oh man.
We're 150 meters close to a cliff.
Oh yeah, no, they're absolutely not gonna be entering any fucking portal after the last game.
There's no fucking way.
They're too scared of them.
They're just afraid of dying.
Tempo, start the game.
Start the game.
Tempo.
Oh my god.
This hide and seek is wild.
What the fuck did I just listen to?
What?
What is it?
It's a It's a clip of Hal talking to Nano.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
That was what I was talking about yesterday about the Anarchist thing.
Anarchist.
Oh, I can't.
Are you friends with Fun?
Yeah, I said to him.
Noba!
Wait, Fun, do I just play Valk?
And just Valk ult away?
Maybe.
Maybe you can get it.
Well, you're Loba.
I'm just gonna be able to get an infinite ulti kill.
Oh, true, true.
You're right.
Oh my god, it's over.
It's over for them.
Now I just have to make sure I never press the Q button.
I'm kidding.
I mean, you just be like, it's an accident.
Yeah, but they dequeued the people last game for getting a kill, so...
Let's go.
Oh, wait, we don't have a beacon character.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
I think we fucked up a little.
I'm in trouble.
I didn't get on path.
No, it's because you did damage.
Yeah, I know.
Damage seed.
Alright, I mean, there's no way.
Go for the support pill.
Yeah, I punched him.
I told them.
I told them you punched him out of fear.
He added all of us.
Why are y'all doing damage?
I thought you were in trouble.
No, we're in trouble.
What did we do?
No, no.
Teppo just added like 10 people and was like, why are you guys doing damage?
I was scared.
It was like fight or flight.
It was my life.
Yeah.
I mean, if you were like getting ran at, you would have punched too.
Give me that bat.
Am I a support character?
Yeah, you are.
Oh, okay.
So I'll be opening support bins.
I got this, guys.
I know what I'm doing.
We need to go get the blue bins, Zoggy.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Now I know what I am.
You collect ammo.
Wait, someone fell out of bounds.
What?
Already?
Yeah.
Guard that bin.
I think that one guy who keeps dying for us is just AFK.
Oh.
Why is he AFK?
I guess like to fill up the slots.
Guard that bin for me.
I swear if some guy fucking comes in and goings that...
That's our points.
Yeah, those are our points right there.
Okay.
Are we just splitting up this time?
Just collecting.
Collecting.
Alright.
I'm going to go to Cascades to get more armor.
How far is your ult?
I'll probably come with you.
I have ult now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll put it in Cascades and hope that no Seekers use the...
Should I get the ultimate increase or...
I feel like I'm always going to die.
So I'll just give you guys my ult.
Alright.
So I'm going to go to Cascades.
Let's see.
I mean, would putting up fences considered a damaging ability?
Yes.
That does damage.
That is how that works.
No, but like just don't walk on it.
Yeah, my bad.
Just walk through it.
No, you're right.
Honestly.
It's a damage by choice.
So like if you just don't walk through it, you should be fine.
Just don't take damage.
Yeah.
Honestly.
Let's go north and grab the pill.
Yeah, I'm going to grab that pill and then put down the ult.
Am I about to die?
Why?
Friendly.
They spawned Varameter.
Me and this Wraith are both like shuffling back and forth like, Yeah, come in!
I'm putting it here.
I'm putting the ult here.
You're welcome.
Let's hope that no Seeker fucking runs in and clocks us.
After this we should probably go...
I'm probably going to go down to Cenote.
I think they're going to leave that side of the map.
There's only one ulti-exile here.
Okay.
We should hurry and take it before these leechers take it.
Got it.
I'm going to go on checkpoint.
I'll see you guys.
Oh, and Nevek.
Guys, if I die in checkpoint, run the opposite side.
Then you'll know.
We got to keep our eyes open.
I found friends.
Wait.
Fun.
Oh, never mind.
I was going to say, Vantage might be broken, but never mind.
I was going to say, because you can see their armors.
Yeah, but like...
They know if they're a three-man.
So if you see a three-man with armor, you know it's the Seekers.
I mean, true, but then they're going to see your fucking skull.
No, no, no.
You can do the passive without going through the Seekers.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You just look at them.
Yeah.
We have one person for information, and then we have Valk to get away.
You know, I feel like...
Wouldn't it be easier just to be Crypto, and then Crypto can just always have a drone out?
Yeah, probably.
Wait, we should do that for Broken Moon.
Just have a Crypto put out the drone out.
And then like...
So the Seeker shoots the drone, then we'll know.
I'll play Crypto, and I'll just EMP everyone.
It's not damaging.
Reptar.
1000 damage.
EMP online.
No, wait, wait.
If you do damage on the last round, it won't count.
It doesn't matter, because it was...
Oh, true.
What are they gonna do?
Kick me out of the tournament?
Yeah, the tournament's over.
Alright.
Where is the...
Alright, nice.
We got purple.
I got the evac too.
Uh...
Take an extra item, reduce his tactical cooldown.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Go...
Wait, where's Fun?
Oh, wait, Fun, you guys are following us?
Fun?
I was collecting.
Follow us?
Yeah, we got purple.
We should split now.
I got a purple helmet.
There's no need for us to be together.
Yeah, we got...
Am I dead?
What was that?
Friendly!
Is he friendly?
I think he's friendly.
Friendly!
Okay, Doki, if you see an enemy in front, okay, run straight to me, okay?
We're gonna valk ult away.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But what if he shoots you?
And the valk ult gets cancelled?
Then GG.
We're both dead.
No, just valk, just leave me.
If I get shot, just leave me and fly away.
No, no, no, no, no.
There's no way he's gonna shoot me.
He'll just be like, I'm gonna shoot the person I've been...
Wait, wait.
No, no, no, that's the ring.
Okay, I was gonna say, the dragon dropped the...
You scared the shit out of me.
He dropped the loot at Valk's and I was like, wait a minute.
He said, wait, I can't see over the ridge.
And I'm like, uh, do you see somebody or not?
What's going on?
I forgot the ring can make them drop the loot box.
I don't know, maybe we can get red.
There's a Pathfinder behind you guys.
Oh.
I think he friendly.
Oh, I'm gonna keep running.
He has a gun.
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Oh, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Wait, I know there's like holes in the rocks.
Dude.
Do you know where the holes in the rocks are?
There should be holes in the rocks.
Okay, okay.
I don't know if both of us being together...
We're also out of zone.
Yeah, we're also out of zone.
Alright, alright.
We should split up guys.
We should really split up.
I'm gonna head this way.
He's climbing stuff, we're good.
Yeah, they're all friendly.
Don't worry.
There's like a friendly guy to my left too.
Alright, I'm gonna go this way.
NRG is expanding now guys.
I'm following you.
Wait, why are you following me?
Oh, I thought he had a gun.
He's just in the med kit.
Oh my god.
I thought it was fucking gone.
All I'm saying is that there's no...
He can't kill us all.
Yeah, Ape Tron, come.
Timmy can.
He can't kill us all.
Did you watch that other endgame?
Oh, that's true.
But there was like 30 people.
And he was out of ammo.
If he had a Havoc, I think all 30 of those people would have been dead.
Didn't he have a Havoc?
He was just out of ammo.
If he had ammo, sorry.
Let me specify.
Wait, wait.
Do you think they're running energy?
Yes, of course.
Okay, we should grab as many energy as we can and throw them off the cliff.
Well, if they're smart, they're just gonna craft it.
Oh...
No, no, look at this.
It's like an Easter egg hunt.
Yeah, it's like a little Easter egg hunt.
If you want more ammo, you gotta find all the ammo.
All I'm saying is if all the hiders work together...
The Keeper's over there.
Wait, how do you know?
I just heard the flatline go off.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Where is he?
Yellow ping somewhere.
I don't know.
I heard it east.
Okay, I'm leaving.
All I'm saying is if all the hiders work together...
There's someone inside!
There's someone inside and they're running around.
I'm scared.
They're running around.
Alright, everyone find your own building.
Friendly!
We all have a building.
They won't know.
Are you friendly?
Guys, leave us alone.
We're scared.
Hello?
Anyone in the building?
Friends only?
I hear so many people walking around.
I don't know, guys.
If it's many people, we're good.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
If you hear one person running, that's when you should be scared.
What if it's one person?
Then it might be a fucking murderer.
So much house.
This is like the Three Little Pigs.
My house is made out of brick.
My house is made out of straw.
We're both in the same type of house.
This is bad.
He's gonna huff and puff and blow our house down.
Don't worry, guys.
It's not.
It's alright.
I'm in a really good spot.
Oh, I don't hear shots.
Oh, they killed Tempo.
Reptar, you see where I'm at?
Do you know where I'm at?
Are you inside?
Like, on top of the vent?
No.
Oh, where are you?
I just heard a rev jump.
Uh oh.
I'm on the roof, but on the inside of it.
Oh.
If he gets murdered, Doki, run straight to me, okay?
We're gonna vocal down.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no way.
You can't get murdered, right?
Oh.
It's him patting.
Where are you?
No, they got rid of the spot up there.
No.
It's Slidy.
They heard the octane jump.
They're coming.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What the fuck?
You're dying to ring.
How are you dying to ring?
They're scared.
Oh, cause they're getting chased into a ring by Peep.
Oh shit.
There's a Pathfinder on me and I hear him.
Okay, well.
It's okay.
It can't be Peep or Luda, so it has to be Timmy.
Yeah, Peep and Luda are both shooting.
No, Timmy's shooting.
Nobody's near us.
We're good.
We're also really far from zone, but we're good.
Wait, this guy just hit beacon on me.
I'm following him.
All of them are hitting beacon.
All of these guys are hitting beacon.
They're all zipping too.
Family.
Wait, there's so many Pathfinders here hitting the beacon.
Come on, Pathfinders.
Let's go.
If you die, we all die.
Let's fucking go.
Pathfinder, strong together.
Oh my god.
Yes, yes we are.
They're zipping for us.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
I'm fucking leaving you guys.
Apes, strong.
No, stay together.
Apes, strong together.
They'll shoot the Pathfinders, not the other characters.
Why does he have a gun?
This guy's got a .8 longbow.
He's using it to scope people out, Fun.
It's actually smart.
I told you, Apes, strong together.
I took a pad.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Now how do I get in a fucking tree?
Fun, look at me.
There's no way.
Help!
Is this a bad tree?
I feel like this is a bad tree.
Is this a bad... no.
Am I onto something or no?
Am I just fucking cooked?
Wait, can I hide here?
Oh god, Fun run!
Fun run!
See you later.
There's no way.
They won't look up here.
They're not gonna look at me either.
There's no way.
They won't look up.
Right?
There's no way.
Oh, he's gonna look up to check the pack.
I feel...
I feel so safe.
I don't.
I feel pretty safe, I'm not gonna lie.
I need a damn adult.
Guys, what are they doing to me?
I think I have an ingenious spot.
Thoughts?
Wait, does that guy have a gun?
No.
I think... I think I blend in.
You see where I'm at?
Yeah.
You think this will work?
Maybe.
Oh, not over there.
Oh, Timmy's next to me.
Timmy's next to me.
Oh, people's next to me too!
It's okay, they won't look up.
They will not look up.
Guys!
Guys, someone has to go on the other side.
They're literally all on our side, guys!
No, I'm not moving.
It's called hide and seek, not run and seek.
I think I'm good.
My spot is so good.
Okay.
Wait.
Okay, have you seen where we are?
No.
No!
I'm still in!
You're still in up there?
I'm still in.
Wait.
I'm gonna redeploy.
I'm running south.
I'm running straight south because they're pushing.
Run!
I'm gonna redeploy.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I'm gonna redeploy.
Luda's on the southwest side of the zone.
I'm going to the southeast.
That guy's a Kraber.
I'm fucking going with him.
I'm gonna redeploy the last 30.
No!
Oh, yes!
You have intel!
I'm out.
Oh my god.
The last 30 seconds.
I'm gonna redeploy.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
I'm here.
I don't know where to go.
There's no way.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
I'm so scared.
Where are all the shots?
I'm just sitting on the rocks.
The rocks are... Highground is your friend, Fun.
Highground is your friend.
You can be evasive from highground.
Okay.
There's four Pathfinders up here, Fun.
I'm gonna do it.
There's three Pathfinders up here, actually.
Not four.
Look at us.
Come here, Fun.
Join the pack.
Family!
Come here, Doki.
Join the pack.
No!
I'm leaving this family.
What the fuck?
Family.
The numbers are going down.
They're dwindling.
Oh.
Stop moving!
Get killed, us all.
Um, I'm just saying one of them is definitely next to me.
Pathfinder strong.
Oh.
Valkyrie strong.
What, you need ulti-exels?
Okay, let me get him after this.
Ready, ready, ready.
Guys.
Run.
He's chasing me!
I have one near me.
Don't come near me!
I have one near me!
I have both of them!
Go back up, go back up, Fun.
Go back up.
I have to pad.
Oh, you gave them ulti.
Yeah, run.
I killed them.
Too scared to look.
Fun.
No!
Oh, god.
I should've jumped behind the pill with that guy.
I should've just jumped behind the pill.
I should've gotten us both killed.
Fun, you gotta live.
You gotta live.
It's just us two.
Am I dead?
No, you're not!
You're not!
It's Tibby on you.
Tibby and Luda.
Oh, god.
Run, Florent!
Oh, god!
Oh, my god!
Run!
He's on controller.
They're on controller.
Uh-oh.
Is he read a play?
No, there's no read a play.
Fun said he has two of them on him.
No!
Okay, okay.
They're stealing each other's kills.
They're not even looking for people.
They're actually teaming up on you.
They're trying to get second, even though second doesn't matter.
Wait, this is a deep hole.
What the fuck?
What is this spot?
I didn't even know this existed.
You're fine.
Don't panic.
He doesn't know.
I don't know about this spot, so I know Luda does not know about this spot.
Who told you this?
What is this?
I don't know!
I just walked in!
Yeah, go finish your Narc Turtle.
That's Narc Turtle.
Go finish her.
The Horizon.
That is?
Oh, god.
I think so.
I'm like 99% sure.
It was.
It was Narc.
Yes, it was.
It was.
Okay, that was worth it.
We died.
That was worth it.
That's why I'm the new IGL.
He's probably so mad.
He just got finished.
He's like, what the fuck is this Loba?
Oh my god.
Back up more.
Back up.
You're behind the Pathfinder.
Why did you put a step?
You fucking whore!
It's okay.
You're top 10.
We're fine.
We didn't do damage.
He was already dead.
It's not damage if he's dead.
Bro, we're so fucked.
I'm literally hiding behind somebody else's body.
Get ready to queue.
Oh, god.
Wait, we the people?
Wait, we the...
What the fuck?
Wait, stop, stop, stop.
That's a Seeker.
It's a Seeker.
I was like, why me?
There's literally a Pathfinder.
You started punching him back.
You're not real.
I'm so confused.
I'm like, what is he doing?
There's no way you started punching him back.
I'm not dying.
I'm just fucking around.
No, there's no way I did damage.
There's no way I did.
Holy fuck.
I thought...
I thought he was hiding.
It's okay.
It was worth it.
Yeah, it was self defense.
It was self defense.
I thought he was hiding.
I don't think that's how that works in this tournament.
It was self defense.
Oh my god.
I need water.
Holy fuck.
I think this Octane wins.
Wait, no, there's someone behind him.
Wait, there is?
Yeah, he's healing behind him.
No, there's only two Seekers left.
One died in zone.
Peeps died in zone.
Again?
Yeah, you guys didn't see it?
I saw it.
No, he got res.
He should have kept him dead.
Because he got a kill after.
There's nothing he can do to keep taking zone damage.
He's like one dick at a time.
They have no ammo.
They're just beating his ass.
Bro, no Octane.
Wait, you got second.
Oh!
That's funny.
Has anyone had the reaction to our XIGL's That's a finisher.
Pass the clip along.
Pass the clip.
Yeah, pass the clip.
He said, please tell me that's not who I think it is.
Oh god, he knew immediately.
Button, pass the clip.
I sent it to you.
It's too good.
I was watching it.
Okay, guys.
Here's the clip, guys.
That was so funny.
He's like, buddy.
What do I mean I'm getting finisher'd right now?
I like how the POV is to somebody else.
So he's not even sharing with me.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Okay, what are we doing now?
What comp?
I don't know.
I'm gonna play Altar on Broken Moon.
I'm gonna play Pound.
It's time to run.
I'll play whatever.
And grapple under a bridge.
We'll be hiding under the bridge.
Alright, alright.
Are we...
Are we doing the same thing?
Five teams tied for first?
Oh my god, that means they have to donate to five different charities.
Them's the rules.
True.
That's the rules.
Those are rules.
Charity rules.
If they don't do it, they hate charity.
It's true.
It's actually facts.
I didn't think about it that way.
How could you hate charity?
I'm an asshole.
Tempo, you can't just hate charity like that.
You gotta donate to five different charities.
I wonder if Wig was reacting to it.
I wish Wig was watching our stream.
Alright.
Let's see.
Should we still have ring characters?
Oh wait, no, you're on crypto.
Reptar, aren't you on crypto?
What were you gonna play before?
I was gonna play Alter.
Wait, I can do crypto.
You can play crypto, go for it.
Yeah, I'll do crypto.
You can hide in a little hole and just get on your Gameboy and play around.
Yeah, I'm bringing season four back.
All this solo crypto.
Just fucking scanning people for army.
And kill points.
Yeah.
You can just start driving your drone at rat.
Oh, you're right!
I can drive my drone?
Wait, I kind of want to play crypto.
You can rat other people out.
I'm gonna rat other people out 100%.
Alright, yeah.
You do crypto.
I hate crypto.
It's so weird.
It's so hard to play.
There's so many buildings this map.
There's no way they find me.
This is where we get top 3.
I need to go watch peepsvod.
How did he die twice to zone?
I need to hear his reaction.
Oh that's true.
How did he die twice to zone?
There's no vod man.
Peeps is embarrassed.
He deleted a vod right after his first death.
Do you have the extension?
Oh yeah the twitch rewind.
If you have it, it says view and download stream without ads.
Watch the current vod.
How did this man die?
Is this the last game?
Yeah.
I died to oob like 3 times in one scrim block.
Wait he's just stuck in this room.
Wait peeps?
Yeah he got stuck in...
Wait how did he get stuck?
He killed people in a building in zone 6 and he had no meds.
He just got stuck in the corner of the room.
I thought like he got stuck as in there were so many bodies just blocking.
Maybe we all... so we all jump out the ship and we all jump out the ship.
We should do that.
Yeah.
We gotta do that.
I can hit ring consoles when I get blue.
I can... wait am I doing loba?
What should I do?
Wait I'll do... I'll do... yeah I'll do loba.
I was just thinking maybe like...
Bangalore?
Cause no one's playing assault characters.
Oh you're right.
What if I bang all of them?
I think I'm gonna be assaulted accidentally.
What do you mean by... depends on what you mean by accidentally.
For the last zone.
What if I had a calculated ALGS bangalore?
Yeah what if...
For ring 6.
And I'd be like oops.
It's like...
Wait bro how... how peep died in the first game is even funnier.
He's just running around stimming you on the gas edge.
It just barely ticks.
It just just shoulder in the zone and dies.
What you didn't click crypto.
You forgot crypto.
Oh wait you're right.
It's okay I'll...
Thank you.
It's on me.
I was afk I was watching the clip.
You can start griefing people now.
It's my turn to grief people.
Okay now instead of...
This is up accidentally bang halting.
Let me accidentally...
Wait there's so many beacons.
There's so many beacons.
Can you land here Doki?
Which way?
And hit all three of the beacons?
Oh yeah.
Hell yeah.
I'm gonna go experimental labs.
Wait can I do both...
Um...
Yeah.
Ring?
No no no no.
You can get in your drone and hit all of the man scan ones.
Oh okay.
From 200 meters.
So if you ping the... the thing and you're 200 meters out you can do that.
Alright.
Alright let's see.
Oh 100.
Alright here we go.
It's time to play on my stream deck.
How do I do this?
Okay I have...
You have to hold the button down to get into the drone.
Time to put...
Get into my steam deck right now.
Oh there we go.
Alright let's see.
Let's see where's the first one.
Wait there's so many.
Why are there two here?
Okay.
No it's too far.
Wait no.
Did I not make it?
No fuck.
You can just run forward.
Yeah.
Leave you a drone.
Just don't worry.
My wifi is on five bars.
Is that that good connection?
I think so.
I hope so.
I ran out of crypto wifi.
You see if you get the Nokia modem you'll never run out of wifi.
I hope so.
I feel like I'm on the same level as the last person here.
Oh.
Wait can I grab armor with the drone?
Bun, do you see...
No.
...anyone in the man scan?
Nooo.
No.
Why is it bugged?
I don't...
I've never seen that before.
I don't know.
I should be able to grab a...
Oh, no, he punched it.
Because my drone was right next to the Evo.
So I was like, how the fuck did he destroy it?
Increase neural link and EMP range.
Wait, what's neural link?
Take the other one.
Okay.
Because that one is like...
The neural link is like when it shows how many teams are in the area, I think.
Oh.
I don't actually know.
Well, isn't that good for the... for high...
Yeah, but flying drone is faster is better, so they can't break that shit.
Oh, okay.
Because you're never EMP'ing anyways.
That's why that first one is good.
But shouldn't we... when we want them...
I'm in God spot.
When we want them to shoot it, so we know where they are.
Oh, but you want to be able to fly around them longer?
So they have to shoot it and like be a little flyer on their head, you know?
Yeah, and they waste their ammo.
Oh, you're so smart.
They waste all their ammo.
That's why you're ranked.
Oh, you're so smart.
You're ranked one, Fred.
Yup.
You're so smart.
All right.
Let's see.
How far is this?
Okay, 280.
I have to get closer.
Getting on my Steam Deck.
Okay.
The most proud we are.
The harder it is to have each other's back.
What are you doing there, Fun?
I'm gonna go to the beginning.
Collecting.
Oops.
More collecting.
Don't worry.
I'm heading.
I'm flying in.
Flying in.
I hope a seeker doesn't randomly shoot me because I'm just in the middle of nowhere.
This Pathfinder just stole my brick.
I'm so sad.
Kill him.
Where are these people anyway?
Let's see.
There's another scan here.
I fucking see.
Come on.
I was like, who the fuck is this guy?
Drone scan persists for 1.5 seconds.
We should want that.
Yeah.
Both are fun.
All right.
Going for the labs.
Who's that behind me?
I need a helmet.
I don't like the sounds behind me.
Is the Pathfinder having a hard time?
I'm going to start going.
Seekers are usually just sitting around the edge, I feel like.
Yeah.
I mean, that makes sense.
Do they know zone or no?
I mean, no.
They don't have zone character.
Okay.
I should go.
Whoever Pathfinder is.
Wait, they already rezzed?
They're probably doing it for Evo.
I was going to say, like, what?
Is this Nock?
It looks like his fucking Pathskin.
I'm going to scan.
Have fun.
We can sit up here.
You know about the squat?
All right.
How many squat?
Wait, Linkster fell.
Was he trying to set up another fucking capture?
Was it him who did it the first time?
He has voice lines off.
Fuck.
Fun.
You like my squat?
I've revered the enemy's positions.
Ooh.
Oh, I have flight mode?
What is flight mode?
Oh.
Uh, I'm sure.
What the fuck is this Pathfinder doing?
Huh.
There's a Pathfinder right...
If I put a drone right on top of this Pathfinder...
You can't do anything about it.
Guys, look up here!
I don't know if I can see you.
Wait, is that Nock?
That is Nock.
He's over here.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, he kicked my drone!
He kicked it!
No, that sucked up!
This guy destroyed my drone.
Just go follow Nock around.
Which one?
He's on the left wall.
He's right there.
I'm gonna throw my drone out.
Just hope I don't die from this.
I'll let you know if anybody's running at your building.
.
Okay.
I'm waiting.
Almost repaired.
Bro, one of them fucking punched my drone!
Wait, should we stream time?
Nock, go get a live reaction.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, you're taking damage?
That's fucked up.
Is he punching you?
Is that him?
Yeah.
No, there's this guy.
There's this guy right here.
This guy.
I'm gonna scan him.
Do you see him?
I'm gonna...
Why do I just ult this man?
That's fucked up.
Wait, am I...
No, I'm not in zone.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Look at him.
Right here.
No, a zone ends here.
Oh my god!
Bro, he got it!
What the fuck?
I just watched him do that on his stream.
I don't have enough beds for this!
Do you have beds?
I only have two shields.
Oh my god.
Bro, kick this guy out!
Kick him out and never invite him to a tournament again.
Broled.
I'm gonna EMP.
I'm gonna fucking EMP.
Where is he?
Broled.
I have EMP.
Where the fuck is he?
Wait.
Where is he?
Where's that Pathfinder?
He's above the rail.
The rail?
He's right here, against this wall.
This wall?
This one?
Behind the building.
Is that him?
Pathfinder on the wall.
Yes, that's him.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I can't help you.
Bro.
There's also this Pathfinder right here.
Let me just shoot a zip at it.
He's creeping so hard.
He's actually so mad.
I'm at the sky.
I got to the fucking left.
Holy shit.
Bro, he destroyed my fucking...
...trip.
He keeps shooting my drone.
Drone.
I got to shoot a zip at that.
Wait, we need to make a web.
Make a web, Pathfinder.
I have another drone coming in.
Don't worry.
You should have taken the other perk.
No, you would have had your drone twice as fast.
No, I should have.
I didn't expect this to get broken as much.
I'm so much.
Why is everybody shooting my drone?
Can we just get ulti cells and keep EMP'ing Nock?
Yeah, let's just keep EMP'ing.
I have one.
What are you gonna do?
Kick us out of the tournament?
It's over.
This is the last game.
Honestly, this is more content.
It's not an early game anyways.
Here, get out of your drone.
I got a present.
Okay, nice.
Ooh, nice.
Okay.
Wait, there's a bunch of fucking loot here.
I'm taking it all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get all that loot.
I just shot a zip at him.
Okay.
I'm almost close.
I'm almost close to another ult.
This Lothlis is stealing all the ammo.
Where is all the other...
Chat, I need a god rat spot.
Oh!
That's a wingman!
What the fuck?
This guy's a wingman!
Wait, I can EMP.
Oh, wait, what's that?
I know!
Wait, I haven't chopped in the corner.
I haven't chopped in the corner.
No!
He destroyed it!
Come up here, chop him in the corner.
Wait, no, I got a spot.
Okay.
No, a mantle!
No, a mantle.
Mantle.
Guys, we're in zone.
We're safe.
We're so safe.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I have EMP.
I have EMP whenever.
I'm ready.
Oh my god!
Wait, what's the next ring?
Let me out!
Okay.
Steam deck, let's go.
Don't EMP anybody but Nock.
Alright.
Where's...
Where is everybody though?
I'm going back up on my spot.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm gonna find rat out people if I can.
Is there any rats?
There's just like nine people in your spot, right?
And Jimmy's over there.
They're all on me?
Alright, I'm getting them all killed.
Leave me alone.
I'm handling my fucking...
My drone right now.
Wait, there's actually like six people up here.
There's two people in this spot.
Oh my god.
Are there any rats here?
Where can I go?
Don't worry, Seekers!
I'll help you find out the rats!
Come scan my spot, Doki.
How many people are up here actually?
Just a few.
Wait, I'm gonna bring a Seeker.
I'm gonna bring a Seeker over there.
Okay, no that's... I'm gonna bring a Seeker.
Wait, I think that...
This is one right here, I think.
Come over here.
He's running rampart for a minigun.
Oh my god.
Come over here.
Bro!
I can take it one more time!
Just start driving at people.
Yeah, come over here.
Yes!
Look up!
Over here.
Come on!
Rampart over here!
Right over here!
Right over...
She's up front.
Oh yeah, here.
I'll follow him.
Don't worry.
I got you!
He's right here on the roof!
Come on!
Rampart, no!
No!
I can't!
I have a big spot!
What an asshole.
It was the perfect spot!
Alright, Donkey, you're gonna get your building cleared in a second.
Just so you know.
If he clears my building, I'm gonna ult.
You don't have drone.
How are you gonna ult?
By sheer will.
He's running into your building right now.
I'm giving you light pigs.
Light pigs.
He's inside.
Don't look through.
No!
I gave you a warning.
I couldn't run anywhere!
I couldn't stop there.
Why would I run?
I gave you a 30 second warning.
And you decided to sit there and say, If he clears my building, I'll EMP him.
I was so close to my EMP though.
You don't understand.
It was so close.
Go on, get banner.
I'll rez.
Oh yeah, get the banner.
Do it, do it, do it, do it.
I'm just trying to stay alive right now, man.
There's a lot of people.
They got weapons and shit.
But all I'm saying will be really funny.
If you get my banner.
Where do we rez you?
I got it.
Don't worry.
Wait, you have a mobile rez?
I'm scared.
No, wait!
How are you gonna rez me?
There's a mobi over here.
Oh, they're using it!
No!
Quick!
There has to be a mobi somewhere!
Someone has to have a mobi!
Nobody lose!
What do you mean?
Somebody has to have a mobi!
Oh my god.
Oh, Britha.
You're fucking ballsy for that.
What do you mean?
But I got you with UAV, bro.
Thank you, sir.
Oh my god.
Bro, you're fucking next, man.
Whoa!
Wait, unless...
Unless...
They already cleared this spot.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Gamers don't look up.
Oh, that was...
Let me in.
Please, please, please, let me in.
Friendly!
Please, please, no!
Let me in.
Break the door.
You know you want to.
Come on.
Break the door.
Your building was stolen.
If you didn't clear that room, you were still good.
Oh my god.
What is this violence?
Bro!
Where's the other Pathfinder?
It's okay, Fun.
I've got the boys.
It's okay.
We've got the team.
We've got the fellows.
There's our Moby.
You know you want to.
No, don't.
They're gonna get to the Moby.
Don't do it.
I really want to.
Where are you?
He's literally in the rock.
I'm waiting for you to set the zipline too, Fun.
I just...
Oh.
Well...
I just took it late.
Wait, they actually got the rez off.
What the fuck?
Oh, he's heading over.
He's heading over to you.
Oh no.
Oh, he's heading over.
Timmy, don't look up.
Timmy, don't look up, Timmy.
Stop looking up.
Look down.
Timmy, don't.
You already won for charity.
Oh, nice.
I'm at 66%.
You should have used the alt-accel for yourself.
Wait, do you have the increased fuel?
Yeah.
Do you just hit the fucking...
I hit the float.
Bro, they're just gonna duck hunt you.
What are you doing?
They can't.
They don't have the fucking ammo for you.
I'm gonna go to the roof.
They have other fish to fry.
Oh my god, everybody's just...
Wait, there's another Moby right there.
Plug, plug.
Plug, plug, de-rez.
Oh.
Bro, the loudest fucking kill ever.
It's so quiet.
I'm in the air.
They're not hearing shit.
You have oob timer.
Safe.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
So safe.
They're not gonna go up the roof.
Keep dying to ring it, keep.
Keep dying to ring.
Peep.
There's no way.
I need to see.
Did he get rez?
About this time, I don't think.
They just gotta leave him.
Oh my god, I just had a heart attack.
Man, if I was still alive, I could have droned so many people.
Oh my god.
The fucking rap part.
That noise.
Bro, that shit's scary.
I think he's gonna clear a roof.
Wait, they're rez-ing.
No, no, no, there's no way.
He's gonna go for the rez.
Wait, there's two Mobys next to you.
Are they using it?
They might, they might, they might.
Bro, what the fu- Oh my god.
Bro!
We're dead!
There's no way!
There's no fucking way!
You died for that!
I'm not dead!
What are you saying?
You stole that shit.
I'm not dead.
Oh no!
You don't mean I died for that.
I'm not dead.
Run.
Wait,
you're alive.
What about my drone?
Oh my god.
What about my- Just throw it out.
Just throw it out.
Just don't get in it.
Okay, maybe I won't.
It's okay, he's not gonna clear you.
I'm leaving you.
Wait, is there any more Mobys?
If there's a Moby, you can plug us.
I don't think I'm gonna be flagging a Moby.
You guys are- The drone insta-hits it.
It insta-hits it.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
Slowly.
Oh!
Oh, you're good!
Go, go, go, go!
To the left!
Go all the way to the left!
You're good, just get on top of the- No, no, no, chill, chill, chill, you're fine.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go, they're killing everyone else!
They're killing everyone else!
No, no, no, don't flash your shield!
Don't flash your shield!
Don't do that!
No, no, no!
No!
Enemy!
It's colluding!
We got third, we got third.
It's okay.
It's literally his teammate.
Oh my god!
I should have droned.
I should have droned!
The rest was worth it, wasn't it?
You were the survivor, not me.
It flew away.
SMH, teaming, teaming.
Teaming, teaming.
They're teaming.
Okay, this man Peep has got to get off on me.
What a fucking snitch!
Yeah, finally they snitched us!
We got creeped.
It's okay.
We got third place in the end.
We got third place.
It's okay.
Jimmy had to rez them both again.
Wait, really?
All I'm saying is they should have rotated Seeker.
Alright, Zone, what's your favorite charity?
Who won charity?
Who won the charity tournament?
Not us.
We don't know that!
We could have clutched it out in the end.
Yeah.
That was fun though.
That was fun.
Yeah, that was really fun.
Stopped that hard in a minute.
That was pretty fun.
You know what?
I had a great time with you guys.
That was fun.
That was a lot of fun.
I was so early.
That was my only great thing.
Yeah, that's the only issue I have.
That it was so fucking early.
Dead.
That was so, so, so tired.
Be funny and knock one.
Wait, did they actually win?
Yeah.
Like overall?
What the fuck?
How?
Oh, they won the last game, so...
Oh, they won the last one too?
Where's the points?
Yeah, where's the points?
It's rigged.
253 points.
How dare they.
Timmy really said screw Loba, I'm just gonna play Rampart.
Oh my god, that Rampart ult was scary as fuck.
He jumped in.
I don't know how he got in behind me like that.
He like dropped off the balcony.
Is that the best part when it's a surprise for you?
You know?
No comment.
All I can say is thank you for watching.
I'm saying is that like they should deduct the Seekers for points for dying to the ring twice.
Like at that point they should have their points deducted.
GG's guys.
Have a great time.
It was nice meeting you, Rektar.
It was really nice meeting you.
If you had any part of the invite, thank you for the invite.
Yeah.
It was great.
I'm gonna go peace out now and talk to my chat.
GG's guys.
Good luck with your scrims.
GG's.
Alright guys, I'm gonna leave NRG.
Oh, you're leaving NRG?
Yeah, guys, sorry.
I hate to break it.
I have to leave NRG because they weren't paying me enough.
So, I'm sorry.
It's really like that.
I'm sorry guys.
I gotta leave.
I got an offer for another team.
So I gotta leave you guys.
My teammates are always getting poached, man.
Sorry guys.
So, good luck.
I hope you guys find a new IGL in time to replace me.
We'll just pick up that freaking Nocturnal guy again.
We'll pick the old one.
I guess.
I know it won't be the same, but like, you know, maybe, you know...
Maybe you'll get far.
You know, maybe...
Alright, GG's.
GG's guys.
Bye bye.
Hey guys.
That was really fun.
I had a great time with Rektar and Fuzz.
Chat.
It was my first time playing with Rektar.
So, fun invited Rektar.
Cause like, I talked about this before.
I was like, desperate to find like, substitute teammates.
Literally, I got fun and Rektar in on like, I think on like, Monday or something.
Like on the 27th.
Because we had like, issues with finding substitutes.
And like, huge shout out to FUN for grabbing me.
And grabbing a third for me.
Cause I was like, I cannot give up.
I was just like...
I was just like, I give up guys.
I can't.
I give up finding a third team.
You can do it FUN.
But it was a great time.
I wish we could use cars.
I feel like if we were able to use cars.
It would have been better.
I really wanted to do my armored car strat.
That would have been so good.
Hey guys.
I'm going to read Super Chats real quick.
And then we're going to...
I'm going to take a nap.
And then get ready for the members stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
10 AM is brutal.
Am I right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
10 AM.
It was a lot.
I'm not used to waking up before 12.
Chat.
I'm so not used to waking up before 12.
I did it.
Huge shout out again to Nokia.
For inviting me to the tournament.
And for sending a little care package over.
And everything.
So yeah.
This was apparently the very first esports tournament ran on wifi.
It still counts.
It's still an esports tournament.
Because pro players were in it.
Pro players plus me.
So yes.
This was apparently the first one on wifi.
And they sent me a free modem.
But yes.
Thank you guys.
Thank you to Nokia again.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
Oh my god.
One funny story before I leave.
The day one for WrestleTuber got flagged for adult content.
And I was like what the fuck.
I was like how?
And then.
I told my youtube guy.
I was like hey.
Can we remove this flag?
Cause we got age restrict.
We got age restrict your WrestleTuber vibe.
And then.
I messaged my youtube guy.
And it got instantly taken off.
Like the age restriction.
Was instantly taken off.
The moment I messaged.
Cause they were like oh yeah.
Dude crap.
Cause like I don't know.
It got age restricted.
I was like why?
Why did it get age restricted?
Anyway.
I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.